there's been a lot of discussion about
that
r number the number of people an
infected person passes the disease
too in the government press conference
today they put our between 0.7
and 1 that's slightly higher than it was
last week but
have a look at this cambridge university
has estimated the r number
for each region in the country now r8
are typically expressed as a range
we're showing you the average of that
range here as you can see
the r8 in london is now by far the
lowest
of all the english regions with the
exception of the midlands
every other region has an r over 0.7
as you can see the northeastern
yorkshire they're at fairing
the worst this matters because once you
factor in the range some of those
figures are
edging close to one and once the rate is
above one
the disease would be spreading rather
than receding
the number of daily infections tells a
similar story there's again
big geographical disparities in the
north those numbers
top 4 thousand in london it's estimated
to be as low as 24.
now it's important to say that this is a
modeled not an exact number and it sits
within
a range in fact the government
scientific advisory group
think that that number of 24 in london
is misleadingly low
they estimate that yesterday alone there
could have been roughly a thousand
new infections in london but
nevertheless
this still tells us that london is
currently faring reasonably well
and it suggests that different regions
might be at different stages in their
outbreaks
it's a similar picture when you look at
the pace at which infections are falling
one is taking roughly two weeks in the
northeastern yorkshire for that
infection rate
to half it's taking just 10 days in the
southeast and roughly four
in london now some scientists think that
this margin of error when you break it
down regionally is high
but it could still provide an argument
that lockdown should be eased at
different times
in different regions however that looks
a little
unlikely when you drill down to local
authority level let's take the north
west
as an example baron infines there had
825 deaths per 100 000. that's the
highest
in the country while places like eden
had only 178.
the cambridge scientists also gave us a
fascinating insight into how the disease
might have been spreading in different
age brackets they think that
18 of 5 to 14 year olds may have already
had the disease but over here only three
percent
of the over 75s that matters because it
shows that the shielding of older people
might have been working now we know that
sadly fatality rates are much higher
amongst the elderly
both regional and demographic
differences could play into policy
in the coming weeks